lake mead is at its lowest level ever  right now sitting at  1067 feet today the head of the water  authority emphasized that everyone needs  to do their part to conserve water  these images show the plunge in water  levels that led to that federal water  shortage declaration at lake mead it's  fallen more than 100 feet in two decades  southern nevada gets about 90 percent of  our water from the colorado river the  ongoing drought conditions projected to  drop water levels even more in the  coming years  speaking bluntly i think the development  going forward is going to need to have  different considerations in water usage  than what we have done  historically so that is a work in  progress  the water authority reminding folks to  follow the water restriction schedules  all year round and to report water waste  this year's water usage is on pace to be  higher than the three year average